Raman: Hello, everyone.
I am T.V. Raman.
And this is my office mate.
Chen: Hi, I'm Charles Chen.
Raman: And this
is our Labrador,
the Web-famous dog.
And we are here
to plug our session
on EyesFreeAndroid.
Um, this work
is really focused
on using your Google Phone
in environments where
you're either not capable of
or unable to or unwilling
to look at the screen.
I do not believe a Smartphone
should be used like this.
I believe you should
be able to use it like this.
I want to be one-handed.
I want to be able to use it
in environments
where my eyes are busy.
We've been doing a bunch
of research work
on using interfaces
that work
for that modality
of interaction
using the touch screen.
Um, you can see some of this
on our EyesFreeAndroid
channel on YouTube.
A bunch of research
has gone into this
in terms of what works
as far as user interaction
is concerned.
And, you know, with time,
we've distilled that
into a few lines of code
that can be culled
from a [indistinct].
Um, so the goal
of this talk
will be to walk you through
the thought process
that led to some of these
UI innovations
and show you how they
actually work in practice.
Chen: Right,
so we'll go through
both the text-to-speech
library
as well
as the gesture UI library
that we've developed
and open sourced.
And we'll then go
into a deep dive
through an example
of a music file browser
that lets you
browse music files
on your SD card.
And we will show how,
in about ten lines of code,
you can add full
text-to-speech functionality
that enables speech feed--
spoken feedback
for browsing
and other actions.
And then we will show how,
in a few more lines of code,
you can easily add gestures
to the system,
and thus create a complete
eyes-free experience.
Raman: So we hope you can
join us at Google I/O.
It should be a lot of fun.
We have a lot more
good stuff to show you.
Won't fit in the student
module, though,
so you'll have
to make it there.
Chen: See you there.